so you're a mafioso in the 1940s in a
city like chicago or new york sure
business is good but you've grown tired
of the shooting violence and the general
death sentence you get working in these
cities sure you could try your luck at
bootlegging union busting or other
rackets but they're just so dangerous if
you're not killed by stepping on someone
else's turf you'll probably end up in
jail your first year you're looking for
a fresh start to make your fortune
elsewhere away from all of this well
you're in luck because just 300 miles
from los angeles in the middle of a
desert sits an untapped goldmine for
organized crime a town of unclaimed
territory where prohibition is
non-existent and where mob wars are
unheard of a town that will lift you
from the obscure ranks of the mafia to a
position of true power all with the
added peace of mind that you're not as
likely to be gunned down in broad
daylight
enter las vegas
a small godforsaken town in the desert
that the mafia turned into the ultimate
money printer
if it wasn't for the mafia sin city as
we know it today might not even exist
this is how the mafia built las vegas
[Applause]
thankfully today with the advent of the
internet there are loads of legal ways
to make money without the risk of
getting gunned down and one of them is
crypto that's where ftx.us comes in ftx
is one of the biggest crypto exchanges
in the world when it comes to trading
volume and daily users ftx was built by
people who trade crypto who know how
annoying transaction and withdrawal fees
can be that's why they made fts one of
the cheapest exchanges out there with up
to 85 percent lower fees compared to
competitors unlike other crypto
exchanges fts has no fixed minimum fee
for transactions no ach fees and no
withdrawal fees you can even get a
crypto debit card so you can spend your
bitcoin ethereum or whatever at any
major crypto accepting vendors just like
how you would normally use a debit card
plus you can buy top ethereum isalana
nfts right now on the ftx app and you
can earn free crypto on every trade you
make over ten dollars and getting
started is quick and easy all you have
to do is go to the link in the
description below download the app and
sign up and then you'll get access to
the crypto exchange that's trusted by
over 6 million people and has marketing
partnerships with stephen curry major
league baseball tom brady and more pause
the video and click the link in the
video description below to get started
now thanks to ftx for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
[Applause]
las vegas is a pretty new city before
1931 it was not much more than a small
town then the construction of the hoover
dam started and suddenly thousands of
workers poured into the area to work on
the projects they would come over to las
vegas on the weekends looking for some
entertainment and would eventually hang
out around the few places that offered
card games with thousands of men looking
for a chance to gamble and enjoy
themselves local businesses and outside
investors quickly started building small
theaters and salutes where the men
couldn't unwind nevada had escaped
prohibition so the alcohol ran freely
and so did the money from the workers
pockets one of the first groups to take
notice of las vegas's massive earning
potential was the mafia they got
involved in the small time gambling
operations early on but that all changed
in 1931 when the opportunity of a
lifetime came along nevada legalized
casinos and the race was on to be the
first movers in this gold rush
[Music]
most las vegas gambling joints created
in the 30s survived on their regular
customers the people who would come week
in and week out to blow a little bit of
their paycheck at the card tables but
then world war ii came around and
suddenly thousands of soldiers were
being transferred to bases in the nevada
desert for training and on their days
off there was only one thing to do
visit las vegas this influx of new
customers meant that the few mob bosses
who were keeping an eye on the situation
suddenly started paying a lot more
attention
thomas hull opened el rancho in 1941 and
made thousands of dollars from his
gourmet buffet and gambling another
millionaire came to town and opened the
hotel last frontier these were the guys
who pioneered the idea of a hotel casino
but they wouldn't be the ones to make
them famous that would be the mafia's
job the mob bosses of chicago and new
york were desperate to get their foot in
the door and their chest finally came in
1941 when nevada legalized betting on
horse races and the only man offered the
job was benjamin buxy siegel
[Music]
as a new mobster in town there's a lot
you can learn about what happened to
buzzy siegel he was sent to las vegas by
his new york bosses back in 1945 at
first his job was to set up illegal
wires that would transmit horse racing
results from las vegas to new york by
controlling the wires he controlled the
buggies and the gambling down to use his
services but it was still a small time
racket it was clumsy and not elegant and
buzzy hated being portrayed as either of
those things he had big dreams for vegas
and he knew exactly how to make them
come true by opening a casino for the
mob so in 1946 buxy seagull convinced
the bosses back home to invest in a
casino development that needed cash this
development went by the name of the
flamingo he would turn the flamingo into
vegas's first high-class casino the kind
of place that has a white thai dress
code on paper the idea looked great in
reality his plan was riddled with
problems first he overspent on the
casino's construction and kept changing
the way things were built according to
his vision then when opening night came
las vegas experienced a freak rainstorm
and almost no one showed up when people
finally came to check out the new
gambling spot most of them were turned
away because they weren't following the
dress code let's face it construction
workers and soldiers aren't exactly the
type to have a tuxedo laying around the
flamingo was too early for his time and
even though it eventually became a huge
success buggy seagull had overplayed his
hand and it was time for him to
disappear on june 20th 1947 buxy siegel
was killed in his girlfriend's home in
beverly hills 20 minutes later three
mobsters walked into the flamingo and
declared they were taking over the
operation the mafia had no patience for
incompetence if you're gonna survive in
sin city you're gonna have to learn fast
[Music]
as a newbie mobster in vegas you started
with what almost everyone else did the
skin back before there were security
cameras all over the place and machines
to count the money the casino made most
of these jobs were done by error-prone
humans you knew this and took full
advantage on the orders of your boss
back home you set up a skimming
operation whenever money goes into the
counting room to be counted weighed and
sent off to the casino safes you make
sure a couple dozen hundreds disappear
off the top if you're smart about it you
can stuff a couple hundreds in your
pocket every hour or so the money you
skim gets placed into a locked metal box
and collected by someone you don't know
every mod family gets a percentage of
the skim that's equal to their
investment in the casino with no one
watching the counters and even dealers
learning how to skim chips the major maw
families with stakes in las vegas made
millions every year and as long as you
kept skimming their money you would keep
getting paid and avoid getting killed to
the mob las vegas was an open city a
place where all the different families
could coexist without the constant
killing a true gangster's paradise they
knew that if the violence got out of
hand it would scare away customers so a
verbal treaty was entered into no mob
wars in vegas it was too lucrative of a
city to lose as long as that rule
remained the mob became richer and his
tentacles sank deeper into sin city and
for an enterprising mafioso like
yourself after about a year or so of
skimming to prove yourself it's time to
move on to better and even more
lucrative things
[Music]
your next step is to take some
initiative maybe you've heard about a
new casino project that desperately
needs a cash injection maybe you know
someone who's looking to sell a casino
once that opportunity comes around you
pitch it to your bosses in the glory
days of vegas buying selling and
building casinos and nightclubs was a
great way to launder money your dirty
cash would go into buying or building
the casino and cold hard clean cash
would come out as profits but as the
years went by the cops were starting to
suspect that there were hidden actors in
the vegas casino game and they weren't
wrong
suddenly moving millions of dollars in
cash from new york to las vegas was a
fool's errand a sure way to get caught
you and your bosses needed a new way to
get the funding to buy casinos and who
better to turn to than jimmy hoffa the
leader of the teamster's labor union for
years the teamsters were associated with
dirty money and violence but when jimmy
hoffa became president it was an
opportunity like no other he made an
offer the mob couldn't refuse he would
use the teamster pension fund i.e the
retirement money of blue collar workers
which raked in over 10 million a year
and used that money to acquire casinos
in exchange the mafia would make sure he
stayed in power it was a match made in
heaven over the years you and your mob
family would use millions in teamster
pension money to buy up casinos and
hotels on the vegas strip dunes the
riviera the sands all of those vegas
casinos were once owned by the mob and
to keep your operation looking clean all
you have to do is get a nice law-abiding
citizen to be your front man that way
the public thinks he's the one buying up
casinos that he's the one becoming a
multi-millionaire when in reality you're
the one actually pulling the strings
behind the scenes all the fretment has
to do is look pretty and keep his hands
clean and no fretman did his job better
than alan gleck at one point allen
through the argent corporation owned
four vegas casinos at once while the mob
was running the rackets in the
background everyone was inspired by this
nobody real estate investor who became a
millionaire overnights
money poured into the mob's coffers and
the sin city glory days had arrived and
you plan on enjoying every second of its
by the 60s you're living every mobster's
dream you're in charge of several
casinos pocketing skin money and getting
your cut for services rendered by the
bosses back home you're friends with
celebrities like frank sinatra who
performs at your casinos and life
couldn't be sweeter no one knows you're
connected to the mob and even if they
did you're not in charge of the casino
you're just listed as an employee while
the fratman runs the show life is good
and vegas is safe that is until the
youngsters arrive
[Music]
[Applause]
with over 20 years of experience running
in vegas mob circles you are a seasoned
vet when it comes to spotting
troublemakers and the arrival of anthony
spelatro spells nothing but trouble he's
smart violent head strong and worst of
all he arrives in vegas with something
to prove none of these qualities make
for a good vegas racketeer sent in by
the chicago mob anthony tony spelatro is
supposed to take over the street rackets
and loan sharking but just like buzzy's
seagull he takes a little bit too much
initiative and starts stepping on toast
first he breaks the decade old rule of
keeping mob violence out of vegas and
within his first few months in the city
five bodies wind up in the nevada desert
then he sleeps with another mobster's
wife he's smart but messy and that
proves to be his downfall you see
unbeknownst to the las vegas based mafia
families the fbi have been listening on
their every word for years the fbi have
been wiretapping and bugging every
suspected mob member they could find the
fest new skimming and money laundering
happened in vegas they just didn't have
proof and that's what tony spelatro
started giving them he slips up on the
telephone he says too much about the
things he's seen and slowly the fbi
starts building a case tony creates a
robbery ring the hole in the wall gang
who steals from homes and hotels around
vegas and starts drawing too much heat
in the early 80s the fbi was finally
starting to build a solid case against
the vegas mobsters their highest value
targets alan glick the owner of four
casinos run by the mob he was brought in
for questioning and immediately starts
singing like a bird glack becomes a
state witness in november 1985 and
suddenly the mob's house of cards comes
crashing down with glick's testimony and
the help of the rico act the cops round
out dozens of mob connected casino
employees those who can flee those that
can bide their time and hope for the
best unfortunately for tony spelatro and
his brother they ended up being tortured
beaten and murdered in a cornfield the
mobsters were arrested tried and all
found guilty with sentences ranging
between 16 and 29 years and worst of all
the hotels and casinos the mob had
monopolized were sold to corporate
organizations vegas is transformed from
a money laundering and racketeering hub
to a clean corporatized tourist-friendly
destination
[Music]
bye
you